- Почему Коломойский вышел грустным из стриптиз-клуба?
- Почему?
- Потому что остался без Привата…
- Ты считаешь, что это смешно?
Так Володимир Зеленський разом з "Кварталом 95"
жартував у грудні 2018 за пів року до своєї перемоги на президентських виборах.
Нині йому, так само як і Ігорю Коломойському, вже не дуже смішно.
Олігарх хоче повернути націоналізований у 2016 році "Приватбанк"
або отримати компенсацію від держави,
а президент прагне отримати гроші від МВФ та уникнути дефолту країни.
Дефіцит держбюджету і паралізована через коронавірус країна на карантині
залишають Зеленському обмаль можливостей для маневрів.
Щоб уникнути катастрофічних наслідків економічної кризи,
Україна може отримати гроші фактично лише у МВФ.
Одна з головних умов - врегулювати процедуру націоналізації проблемних банків,
а у випадку вже націоналізованих - запобігти намаганням
оскаржити рішення держави колишніми власниками.
Передусім це стосується колишнього співвласника "Приватбанку" Ігоря Коломойського,
тому і назвали відповідний законопроєкт "антиколомойським".
Наприкінці березня цей документ неймовірними зусиллями
таки вдалося ухвалити у першому читанні.
Зеленський особисто приїхав у Раду проконтролювати голосування,
яке фактично підтвердило крах монобільшості.
Без інших фракцій достатньої кількості голосів не набралося б.
До розгляду "антиколомойського" законопроєкту в другому читанні
вже подано понад 16 тисяч правок. Це абсолютний рекорд в історії Верховної Ради.
Для порівняння: раніше найбільше правок було
до проекту Конституції, Виборчого кодексу та щодо ринку землі -
за кожний документ - понад чотири тисячі правок.
Так от "антиколомойський" законопроєкт має значно більше правок,
ніж попередні рекордсмени разом узяті.
Найбільше правок подали семеро народних обранців.
Депутат від "Голосу" Ярослав Железняк оприлюднив
список цих "законотворців-ударників". Найбільше правок,
а це понад 6 тисяч, подав мажоритарник Антон Поляков,
якого наприкінці минулого року виключили з фракції "Слуга народу"
через порушення внутрішньопартійної дисципліни та прогули.
Ще шестеро депутатів подали від тисячі до двох тисяч кожен.
У ЗМІ цих народних обранців відносять до так званої "групи Коломойського" у парламенті.
Сам же олігарх заявив, що нікого ні про що не просив
і  що цей законопроєкт є не "антиколомойським", а антиукраїнським.
Формально регламент Верховної Ради не порушено,
але очевидно, що мета цього законодавчого спаму - затягнути час.
На думку оглядачів, це потрібно Коломойському,
щоб виторгувати вигідні для себе умови
в інших сферах свого бізнесу в обмін на припинення спроб повернути "Приватбанк".
Остаточно ухвалити "антиколомойський" законопроєкт можна,
і не лише проголосувавши кожну правку окремо.
Це можна зробити і "пакетом". Але спершу ці правки
має розсортувати профільний комітет парламенту.
Показово, що напередодні голосування комітет не міг зібрати кворум.
на засідання не з’являлося чимало депутатів.
Нині, під час карантину, це буде зробити ще складніше.
До того ж, заступник голови цього комітету - Олександр Дубінський,
а секретар - Ігор Палиця. Обидва не приховують своїх зв’язків з Коломойським.
Щоб просто фізично розглянути понад 16 тисяч правок,
доведеться працювати до кінця осені:
якщо без збоїв, карантину і літніх канікул у депутатів,
вважають опитані DW експерти. Стільки часу в Зеленського немає.
Ані українські олігархи, ані іноземні інвестори чи банки
закрити величезну діру в держбюджеті не зможуть.
Без грошей МВФ фінансову кризу, спричинену коронавірусом, Україні не подолати.